The next best predictor of lifetime
success is conscientiousness.
Well,
so,
and I've though of the two aspects of
conscientiousness say orderliness and
industriousness.
The better predictor is industriousness.
So the question is,
well,
what can you do about your
industriousness?
And the answer to that is,
well that's Kinda rough too because
there's a strong genetic component,
but you can work on micro habits with
regards to your conscientiousness and I
think the best micro habits.
This is partly to do with this future
authoring program processes.
I think the best thing you can do with
regards to your conscientiousness is to
set up some aims for yourself.
Goals that you actually value and the
future authoring program helps people do
that.
And basically it does a situational
analysis of it helps you do a
situational analysis of your life more
than a psychological analysis I would
say.
And so the questions are something like,
well,
all right,
you're going to have to put some effort
into your life and you need to be
motivated to do that.
And so what are the potential sources of
motivation?
You could think about them in the big
five manner.
You know,
if you're extroverted,
you want friends,
if you're agreeable,
you want an intimate relationship.
If you're disagreeable,
you want to win competitions.
If you're open,
you want to engage in creative activity.
If you're high in neuroticism,
you want security.
Okay?
So those are all sources of potential
motivation that you could draw on that
you could tailor to your own,
you know,
your own personality.
But then there are dimensions that you
want to consider your life across.
And so we asked people about,
well,
you know,
if you could have your life the way you
wanted it in three to five years,
if you were taking care of yourself
properly,
you know,
what would you want from your
friendships?
What would you want from your intimate
relationship?
How would you like to structure your
family?
What do you want for your career?
Well,
how are you going to use your time
outside of your job and how are you
going to regulate your mental,
physical,
mental,
and physical health,
and maybe also your drug and alcohol
use.
Because that's,
that's a good place to Auger down,
you know,
because alcoholism,
for example,
wipes out,
you know,
five to 10 percent of people,
so you want to keep that under control
and then,
and then so maybe you know,
you,
you develop a vision of what your life,
what you would like your life to be and
that associates the,
so the goal,
once the goal is established and then
you break down the goal into micro
processes that you could implement the
microprocesses become rewarding in
proportion in relation to there a causal
association with the goal and that
tangles in your,
your incentive reward system.
You know,
we talked about the dopaminergic
incentive reward system,
but that's the thing that keeps you
moving forward.
And the way it works is that it works
better if it produces positive emotion.
When it can see you moving towards a
valued goal,
okay,
well what's the implication of that?
Better have a valued goal because
otherwise you can't get any positive
motivation working out.
And so the more valuable the goal in
principle,
the more the micro processes associated
with that goal start to take on a
positive charge.
And so what that means is while you get
up in the morning and you're excited
about the day,
you're ready to go,
and so as far as I can tell,
what you do is you specify your longterm
ideal.
Maybe you also specify a place you want
to stay the hell away from them so that
you're terrified to fail as well as
excited about succeeding because that's
also useful.
You specify your goal.
You do that,
you do that in some sense as a unique
individual.
You want to.
You want to specify goals that make you
say,
Oh,
if that could happen as a consequence of
my efforts,
it would clearly be worthwhile because
the question always is,
why do something?
Because doing nothing is easy.
You just sit there and you don't do
anything.
How it's real easy.
The question is why would you ever do
anything?
And the answer to that has to be because
you've determined by some means that
it's worthwhile.
And then the next question might be,
well,
where should you look for worthwhile
things?
And one would be,
well,
you could consult your own temperament,
and the other would be,
while you kinda look at how,
look at what it is that people accrue
that's valuable across the lifespan.
Look what,
look what.
So you do a structural analysis of the
subcomponents of human existence and
already good that you need a family.
You need friends,
like you don't need to have all these
things,
but you better have most of them.
Family,
friends,
career,
educational goals,
plans for time outside of work and
attention to your mental and physical
health,
etc. You know those are,
that's what life is about.
And if You don't have any of those
things,
well then all you've got left is misery
and suffering.
So that's,
that's a bad,
that's a bad deal for you.
So,
so once you,
once you set up that goal structure,
let's say,
and that's really in many in many ways,
that's what you should be doing at
universities is that's exactly what you
should be doing is trying to figure out
who it is that you're trying to be,
right,
and you aim at that and then use
everything you learned as a means of
building that person that you want to
be.
And and I really mean want to be,
I don't mean should be even those
things,
those things are going to overlap and
it's important to distinguish between
those because that's partly,
and this is back down to the micro
routine analysis.
So I started saying,
well,
you're going to try to make yourself
more industrious.
Okay?
Number one,
specify your damn goals because how are
you going to hit something if you don't
know what it is that isn't going to
happen.
And often people won't specify their
goals too because they don't like to
specify conditions for failure.
So if you keep yourself all vague and
foggy,
which is real easy because that's just a
matter of not doing as well,
then you don't know when you fail and
people might say,
well,
I really don't want to know when I fail
because that's painful,
so I'll,
I'll keep myself blind about when I
fail.
ThAt's fine,
except you'll fail all the time.
Then you just won't know it until you've
failed so badly that you're done.
And that can easily happen by the time
you're 40.
So.
So I would recommend that you don't let
that happen.
So that's willful blindness,
right?
You could have known,
but you chose not to.
Okay?
So once you get your goal structure set
up,
you think,
okay,
if I could have this life looks like
that might be worth living,
despite the fact that it's going to be
anxiety provoking and threatening,
and there's gonna be some suffering and
loss involved in all of that.
Obviously the goal is to have a vision
for your life such that all things
considered that justifies your effort.
Okay?
So then what do you do?
Well then then you turn down to the
micro routines like,
okay,
well this is what I'm aiming for,
how does that instantiates itself day to
day,
week to week,
month to month,
and that's where something like a
schedule can be unbelievably useful.
Google calendar.
It's like make a damn schedule and stick
to it.
Okay,
so what's the rule with the schedule?
It's not a bloody prison.
That's the first thing that people do
wrong.
He said,
well I don't like to follow a schedule.
Was like,
well what kind of schedule are you
setting up?
Well I,
I have to do this,
then I have to do this,
you know,
and then I just go play video games
because who wants to do all these things
that I have to do?
It's like wrong.
Set the damn schedule up so that you
have the day you want.
That's the trick.
It's like okay,
I've got tomorrow.
If I was going to set it up so it was
the best possible day I could have
practically speaking,
what would it look like?
Well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's going to go along
with that because if you have any sense,
one of the things that you're going to
insist upon is that at the end of the
day,
you're not in worse shape than you were
that then at the beginning of the day,
right?
Because that's a stupid day.
If you have a bunch of those in a row,
you just dig,
dig yourself a hole,
and then you bury yourself in.
It's like,
sorry,
that's just not a good strategy.
It's a bad strategy.
So maybe 20 percent of your day has to
be responsibility and obligation,
or maybe it's more than that,
depending on how far behind you are,
but even that you can.
You can ask yourself,
okay,
well I've got these responsibilities.
I have to schedule the damn things in.
What's the right ratio of responsibility
to reward?
And you can ask yourself that just like
you'd negotiate with someone who is
working for you.
It's like,
okay,
you gotta work tomorrow.
Okay,
so I want you to work tomorrow.
And you might say,
okay,
well what are you going to do for me
that makes it likely that I'll work for
you while you could ask yourself that,
you know,
maybe you do an hour of,
of responsibility and then you play a
video game for 15 minutes.
I don't know,
whatever turnS your crank man,
but you know,
you have to negotiate with yourself and
not tyrannized yourself like you're
negotiating with someone that you care
for that you would like to be productive
and have a good life.
And,
and that's how you make the schedule.
It's like.
And then you look at the day and you
think,
well,
if I had that day,
that'd be good.
Great.
You know,
and you,
you're useless and horrible.
So you'll probably only hit it with
about 70 percent accuracy,
but that beats the hell out of zero.
Right?
And if you hit it even with 50 percent
accuracy,
another rule is well,
aim for 51 percent the next week or 50
and a half percent for god's sake.
Or because you're going to hit that
position where things to loop back
positively and spiral you upward.
And soul,
so that's one way that you can work on
your conscientiousness is a plan,
a life you'd like to have and and you do
that partly by referring to social
norms.
That's more or less rescuing your father
from the belly of the whale,
but the other way you do that is by
having a little conversation with
yourself about it as if you don't really
know who you are because you know what
you're like.
You won't do what you're told.
You won't do what you tell yourSelf to
do.
You must have noticed that.
It's like you're a bad employee and a
worse boss,
and in both of those work for you,
you don't know what you want to do.
And then when you tell yourself what to
do,
you don't do it anyways.
You should fire yourself and find
someone else to beat.
But,
but you know what my point is,
is that you have to understand that
you're not your own servant,
so to speak.
You're someone that you have to
negotiate with and that's.
And you're someone that you want to
present the opportunity of having a good
life too.
And that's hard for people because they
don't like themselves very much,
so you know,
they're always like cracking the whip
and then procrastinating and cracking
the whip and then procrastinating and
it's like,
god,
it's so boring and such a pathetic way
of spending your time.
And you know what that's like because
you probably wasted like six hours a day
and I think we did an economic
calculation about that a while back,
right?
Your time is probably worth 50 bucks an
hour,
something like that.
I mean,
you're not getting paid that now,
but you're young.
And so this is investment time and what
you do now is going to multiply its
effects in the future.
So,
so let's say it's 50 bucks an hour,
which is perfectly reasonable.
So if you waste six hours a day and you
are,
then you're wasting about $2,000 a week
or about $100,000 a year.
So like go ahead.
But that's what it's costing you every
hour.
and you need to know what your damn time
is worth.
So let's say it's not 50 bucks,
it's 30,
whatever.
Maybe it's 100,
it's somewhere in that range.
One of the things you should be asking
yourself is when you spend an hour was
that,
well,
what have I paid someone 50 bucks to
have had that hour,
and if the answer is no,
it's like,
well,
maybe you should do something else with
your time,
and it depends on whether or not you
think that your time is worthwhile.
But the funny thing about not assuming
that is if you assume your time isn't
worthwhile,
what happens is you don't just sit
around sort of randomly in a state of
responsibility list bliss.
What you do is you suffer existentially
and so that seems like a stupid
solution,
so okay,
so anyways,
as far as I can tell,
that's how you can improve your
conscientiousness,
hannah,
outline and goal that you actually would
like to hit and even better,
here's something else you can think
about when you're negotiating in your
life.
You could say if you're kind of
pessimistic,
you'd say,
well,
we have to negotiate an agreement.
I'd like to walk away not miserable and
resentful.
okay,
let's call that a baseline and that's
how you're going to negotiate with your
wife or your husband.
That's a good thing to know.
You want to negotiate so that you don't
walk away miserable and resentful
because that makes you hostile and then
you'll to hurt them and I would say that
unless you want to hurt them and then of
course they'll happily return the favor
unless you.
If you want to exist in a place where
you're basically hitting each other in
the head repeatedly for 30 years,
you go right ahead.
But I wouldn't say that that's a
particularly good way of living.
So you might say,
well,
the minimal precondition for a
successful negotiation is that you don't
walk away resentful and angry.
And so that's also how you know when you
have something to say to someone because
the rule has to be.
If you're going to walk away resentful
and angry,
you've got something to say.
It doesn't mean you're right by the way,
but it does mean that you have something
to say,
but it's kind of a low bar.
You know,
like if I wanted to live with you for 30
years,
maybe we should say,
how about we walk away from our mutual
negotiations?
Thrilled.
Well why not?
You know,
you got to aim for something you could
aim for that you want to negotiate with
your boss for a new seller.
You might think,
okay,
I've got this damn job,
how much would I have to be paid?
So I'd be so bloody excited to go to
work.
I could hardly stand it while you can at
least know what that number is.
And then you could go there and say,
well look,
you know,
you like to have me around.
I've been doing some thinking.
I think if you paid me this amount of
money,
I'd be so thrilled to go to work that
you could hardly even keep me away from
here.
And your boss might think,
wow,
I'd actually really like to have someone
around who would be so thrilled to work
that I can't get rid of them.
so like maybe I'll,
well I can't give you all of that.
I'll give you 75 percent.
Maybe we can renegotiate it in a year.
It's like,
hey,
good deal,
or you can be some weasley coward and go
in there and snuggle about how awful
your life is and walk away,
barely able to tolerate outcome of the
negotiation.
So like I wouldn't recommend that and
it's funny because I've watched people
do this repeatedly in my clinical
practice because I do,
we do.
We plan all the time because the rule is
you're can come and see me.
I'm going to try to help you figure out
how to have the life that you want to
have and we're going to think about that
strategically.
So you're making $50,000 a year right
now.
Maybe you should be making $150,000 in
three years.
And they think,
well that couldn't happen.
It's like not with that attitude.
That's the first thing.
It's like,
no,
that's not going to happen if you,
if you don't ask people for the damn
money,
if you don't look for a better job,
but they're going to come along and just
shovel a boat full of money at you.
It's like,
no,
that's not going to happen,
but if why is that impossible?
Look at you,
you people in here.
it's like,
what the hell is wrong with you?
Nothing.
So you probably have what you want.
If you could figure out what the hell it
was and then you know,
you diligently pursued it.
So.
and then maybe you wouldn't whine about
being alive.
That'd be good because people who whined
about being alive or dangerous to
themselves and other people.
So you might think I can have what I
want,
but you better well figure out what it
is and you can't just wait for the like
have what you want fairy to show up at
your doorstep and granted because
obviously that's not going to happen.
So.
So conscientiousness,
while we talked about how you could
improve that social networking,
that's another big deal.
It's one of the advantages that older
people have over younger people.
And so for example,
now that I'm in my fifties,
roughly speaking,
I know a bunch of other people who are
relatively well positioned in the
dominance hierarchy and they know all
sorts of people.
and so when I go to one of them and say,
can you do x or do you know x?
They say no,
but I know someone who cat.
And that's a huge advantage.
So another thing that you want to think
about as you move through life and this
is,
is that use your ability to network
properly.
And that doesn't mean schmooze and it
doesn't mean go out and impress people.
That's all just complete bloody rubbish.
It means you,
you,
you try to surround yourself with people
who are competent in multiple different
dimensions and you maintain your
relationships with them.
And that's a trading relationship to
right?
It involves research,
reciprocity,
but it's a huge advantage.
A social network is a huge advantage and
that's something extroverted people can
be really good at because you know they
have that sort of social ability and
that goes along with the ability to
sell.
So another place that you can pick up
power and power for the good,
for the right things is to,
is to consciously develop and maintain
your social networks.
And that also means,
well,
let's talk about friendships for a
minute.
Here's how you know,
if someone's,
your friend A you can tell them bad news
and they'll lIsten.
They won't tell you why you know you're
stupid and why that bad thing happened
to you and how something worse happened
to them once and you know,
derailed the whole conversation.
you can actually tell them bad news and
they'll listen.
So that's a good thing.
And then this is a weirder thing.
You can tell them good news
and they'll help you celebrate.
And that's a really good way of deciding
who you should have around you.
Because if you have someone around you,
you know somethIng good happens to you
and you're kind of afraid to even admit
it because you know god,
something good happen to you.
It's like you let that be known and will
certainly be taken away.
So you know,
you come out and you sort of tell
someone halfheartedly that something
good happened to you,
they give you a whack and then talk
about,
you know,
the great thing that happened to them
three years ago or worse,
the great thing that happened to someone
that they knew three years ago,
you know,
it's like go away from that person.
They're not helpful to you and they're
not helpful to themselves either.
And so you want to surround yourself.
You've got to think about this.
You've got to surround yourself with
people who want the best for the best
part of you.
You can hang around with weasels and
losers that are trying to pull you down
to justify the fact that they're
spiraling downhill as well.
And you know,
the upside of that is you don't have to
have any responsibility and he can all
whine about how wretched life is,
you know.
So that's pretty attractive.
But I would say it's also a bad medium
to longterm plan.
And so it's,
it's acceptable and desirable to try to
surround yourself with people who were
facilitating your development.
You know when you might say,
well,
I've got people around,
I know them well,
you know they're,
they're,
they're not doing that well and and
there and they don't fit into that
category.
It's like,
what's your point?
What are you going to do with them?
Exactly.
You feel if they'll listen and cooperate
with you and move towards a better
future,
great.
If they don't pay any attention and they
keep doing the same damn things over and
over and they're not going anywhere and
is painful,
then maybe the proper thing to do is
say,
you just have your misery.
I'll go off and have my life and maybe
you'll wake up at some point in the
future and think that's a better way of
being because just putting up with it is
while they call that enabling,
right?
You put up with that sort of behavior.
You're providing tacit consent for it
and even tacit approval.
It's like it's bad idea.
You have,
I would say both the right and the
responsibility to surround yourself with
people who are good for the best part of
you and that's not the same as you know.
I don't have to elaborate on that.
You can figure out what that means.
Skills,
that's another thing you can do and if
you want to increase your probability of
success every time you have an
opportunity to take an opportunity that
would provide you with a new skill.
Do it right.
Learn to program,
learn to write,
learn to read,
read new things,
learn to public speak.
Learn how to introduce yourself to
people.
Learn how to social network,
learn how to go talk to your boss in a
matter.
This is the right way to go.
Talk to someone who's supervising you.
I see this problem and here's the
solution and so I'm coming to talk to
you about the problem and the solution.
It's like that person is going to want
to talk to you a lot site because the
other people they're talking to,
you are going to come and say,
I've got a problem.
Can you do something about it?
It's like they don't want to do
something about it.
They already got 50 things to do,
you know,
so if you're the person who constantly
brings forth a problem,
even if they're accurate problems,
is why are they going to want to have
you around?
It's you're just,
you're just another problem.
Don't be a problem for the people who
want to give you money.
That's a good rule of thumb,
man.
You know,
if someone wants to give you money,
then help them do that.
And if they want to give you status and
success,
then help them do that.
Right?
And you do that in part by bringing them
solutions and partly you do that by
developing your skills.
And so if things aren't going very well
for you,
this is also a good way of evaluating an
opportunity.
Should you take an opportunity.
Well,
here's the rule,
take the opportunity if it will teach
you something that you can use for other
opportunities because then even if it
fails,
which it probably will,
it doesn't matter because you've accrued
something of value that you can bring
forward to the next situation.
so you know,
there's this old union idea that I told
you about the sharp cathedral,
for example,
the cathedrals made in the form of a
cross and the cross signifies the center
of the world and the dome signifies the
sky and so right below the dome at the
center of the world,
and it's a cross because the cross is
the place of suffering.
So that's the center of the world
because that's what you are.
You're the place of sufferIng,
right?
You're the place of conscious suffering.
that's the center of the world.
And so inscribed on the floor is a maze
and you,
and it's a big maze and it's a mandela
and,
and there's a kind of a flower shaped
resting place right in the center.
And what you're doing is walking in the
maze and you walk all four quadrants and
you get to the middle,
which is where you want to be.
You want to be in the middle.
Well,
how do you get there?
You walk everywhere and what does that
mean?
It means every bloody time you're
offered an opportunity,
take it and develop your skills.
And that's better than wealth by the
way,
in fact,
it actually constitutes wealth because
wealth constitutes what you have when
someone takes all your money away,
right?
That's real wealth.
And so the way that you build up that
sort of wealth is you turn yourself into
someone who's competent in multiple
directions and you can be doing that all
the time,
right?
Especially with the kind of technology
that you people have access to.
I mean,
you can learn anything you want whenever
you want.
So what a good deal that is,
man.
And so there's,
there's easy fruit hanging that you
could pick and I would recommend that
you do that.
So here's an example.
Let's say you're not doing too bad,
so maybe you're in the middle of the
normal distribution,
then you lose your job.
Okay?
And so let's say you're a conscientious
person and we can say just for the sake
of argument,
that you lose your job because of mass
layoffs in your company.
so it has nothing to do with you.
It's fundamentally,
it's just like luck Of the draw
basically.
But then what happens to you?
Well,
if you're conscientious,
you're gonna,
go after yourself pretty hard so you're
gonna add,
especially if you're also high in
neuroticism.
It's going to depress you to lose your
job and maybe you're in a situation
where you just for one reason or
another,
you don't have that many other
opportunities.
Now maybe you should look for them,
but maybe you're in a depressed strata
of the economy or you're geographically
located somewhere that makes moving
difficult or so on and so forth.
You know,
so,
but you lose a job and then you start to
get depressed because of that.
Well then as you start to get depressed,
you know it decreases the probability
that you're going to look for a job,
but it also maybe starts to put stress
on your family and it also starts to
decrease the probability that you're
going to engage in positive social
interaction.
So now not only are you unemployed and
suffering from economic stress,
but you're married just starting to
suffer and you're starting to isolate
yourself from your friends.
And then of course,
as your marriage suffers in the stress
builds up,
then that's going to make you more
depressed and that's going to keep you
even farther away from your friends and
that's going to decrease the likelihood
that you're going to have enough
positive emotion and enthusiasm to look
for another job.
And then you know,
maybe you want to add a bit of a
drinking problem too,
that just for fun and you can see that
you can get a spiral going that's just
taken you down.
Right?
ANd there's all sorts of things because
lots of times people conceptualize,
let's say,
you know,
you're unemployed guy and you go to
counseling and you get a diagnosis of
depression.
And the thing about a diagnosis of
depression,
it's sort of like the assumption is
there's something gone wrong with your
psychological structure.
It's like if you're unemployed and
you're,
you're depressed,
it isn't obvious at all that the problem
is in your head.
You know what I mean?
It's,
it doesn't.
If it isn't even obvious that it's a
psychological problem,
it's just a problem and problems can
take you out.
And so you know,
if you're unemployed and you're under
economic stress and your marriage just
starting to shake and you're isolating
yourself from your friends and you're
less likely to be motivated to go look
for a job,
you can sort of think about that as a
depressive spiral,
but you can also think of it as a
conspiracy in some sense of external
forces that are arguing you into the
ground and we don't tend to
conceptualize psychological disorders
that way,
but we should because lots of times when
people are suffering from something that
you could describe in psychological
terminology and depression is a very
good example of that.
it isn't obvious that there's something
wrong with them psychologically.
Often they just are in trouble and there
isn't a category in psychological
diagnosis for client in serious trouble.
But my experience has been almost
without exception,
that the people that come to see me come
to see me because something's gone wrong
with their life.
Not because they have a psychological
problem.
Now you could say,
well,
there are psychological inadequacies
such as they might be,
are interfering with their ability to
recover or maybe even served as
precursors to,
you know,
increase the probability of the
catastrophe,
but it's still not exactly the
appropriate way to conceptualize it and
you know,
because you're,
there's you inside you and as a
personality psychologist in,
as a clinical theorists,
most of what I've talked to you guys
about is your psyche and its structure
as if it was like a soul that inhabited
you and,
and there's some real utility in that.
You know,
you're an individual demarcated from the
community.
You can be set up in a healthy manner
road,
not unhealthy manner.
The problem with that is that you're not
just an individual,
you're connected to all these external
network dynamic networks that are
really,
really important and it isn't even easy
to separate them from you.
You know,
like you might say,
well this is especially true once you
become a parent is like,
is your child more you than your arm?
You know,
you think it's pretty obvious that parts
of you that are physically linked.
Our more key to you to you as an entity,
but it's by no means obvious.
I think many people would much more
happily sacrifice at arm than a child
you know,
and so your boundaries are not where
your boundaries are located are not
precisely isomorphic with the outline of
your body.
It's not that simple at all,
and so you're embedded in all sorts of
networks that can pull you down rapidly
or elevate you because the other thing
that happens is that,
well,
let's say I've never traded with anyone
and I go up to someone and I say,
well,
do you want to trade?
And they say,
well,
why?
How?
How can I trust you?
And the answer to that is,
well,
you have take my word for it with that's
not.
That's not a very good argument.
You might say,
instead,
well here's what I have to offer and you
can evaluate it,
but the person's likely to say,
well,
I don't know how to evaluate it,
and so I'm still stuck with taking your
word.
So that's a bad problem.
And you'll see that if ever try to sell
a product in the marketplace is if you
don't,
if if the product is new and it's
complex,
then you're forcing the person that
wants to buy it to evaluate it and then
you're forcing them to take the risk of
being wrong as well as the time it would
take to evaluate it and they don't like
that.
WhAt they want is what's often called
social proof,
which is,
okay,
well you want to trade with me.
Who else have you traded with?
And if the answer is zero,
then they are going to say,
well,
you're an interesting person and all
that,
but I've got these other people over
here who've already traded with a bunch
of people and therefore the risk is
lower in part because let's say I have a
supervisor and I'm going to make a
decision and my primary concern is that
my supervisor will not hate me for
making the decision.
It's not my that my primary concern is
to make the best decision.
It's not the same thing.
It's that I want to make a decision that
I'm not going to get in trouble for,
okay,
so how do I do that because I need a
post hoc justification so I buy
something from you and it turns out to
be terrible and,
and I get called for it,
called on the table for it.
And what do I say?
I say,
well,
you know,
that person was buying from it and that
person was buying from,
from,
from him and that person was buying from
him like all these other people were
doing the same thing.
So it's not like the error is localized
in me and that's often a very credible
story.
But if the answer is,
well,
you know,
I,
I have held you waited,
it took,
decided to take a risk.
It's like out the door with you sunday
because you know,
that's just,
that's an indication that you're not
capable of doing that sort of thing.
So I think part of the reason that
people's spiraled downhill into zero is
because po positive feedback,
positive feedback loop is a loop that
increases the probability that the loop
will continue,
right?
A positive feedback loop is you've
experienced this when you hear
microphone feedback in an amplified
system so you know the microphone sends
a message to the speakers and then the
speakers send out the message amplified
and then the microphone picks up the
message and it gets amplified again and
you get this howling occur,
which is can be deafening but can also
destroy the system because it'll keep
amplifying upward until the speakers
blow,
for example.
That'S a positive feedback loop and a
positive feedback loop can spiral you
upward or it can spiral you downward.
And so a virtuous circle,
a virtuous positive feedback loop is
weird.
Well,
I've traded with him and I've traded
with him and I've traded with him and
now I can say to you,
I've traded with these three people and
you go talk to them and they say good
things,
and so then you say,
well,
I'll trade with you,
and then because of that,
then you're even more likely to trade
with me.
And it's like the thing starts to spiral
uphill and it does that,
I think in a nonlinear form.
and so because one of the things you
guys are going to be asking yourself as
you mature,
because what's happening is that income
inequality is increasing,
right?
And you might ask,
well,
why that?
Why is that?
The first thing you need to know is that
that's what income does.
So it's not like you need an explanation
for it.
This is the explanation.
It's like a rule.
If you run a trading game to its logical
conclusion,
one person ends up with all the money
and everyone else ends up with zero.